I'm with Norm who is going to teach me the very basics of stage fighting.
What are you going to teach me, Norm?
We'll start with choking, or strangling properly
We are in an alley by a pub. So this is pretty much prime choking territory(!)
Absolutely it is.
So we're going to start with you choking me.
Okay.
Right, so, the best way to do 'stage choking' or strangling rather
is that you do nothing.
Okay, I like this.
So literally put your hand on my breastbone, chestplate --
Do you want to get in closer on that, so I can see where I'm putting this?
-- Do nothing.
-- Okay.
Let me do all of the work.
I'll grab your hand and go--
That is good!
The key is that I am in control so I can pull your hand in as tight as I feel comfortable with
so for people who are very unhappy at the idea of being choked
Yeah. I do not like anyone being here.
-- So shall I try it on you?
-- Yeah, okay.
-- So you place your hand just down here?
-- Yeah, I'd put it there
And you are now in control and I literally do nothing.
Woah!
There you go!
There we go! Thank you Norm! That is how to stage choke someone
and that is something you might not have known!
Subtitles by naggyman
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]